(upbeat music)
(gun shooting)
- [Narrator] Online
multiplayer games would become
a pretty big deal.
- [Man] Death match and online
gameplay changed everything.
- [Gamer 1] Whoa! What?!
- [Gamer 2] Agh!
- [Narrator] Players could
connect over a network and
interact.
- [Gamer] Look at the death!
- [Narrator] Immersing
themselves in a new world,
- [Gamer] Boom!
- [Narrator] but with each other.
- [Man] For the first time,
you can play at a high speed
3d world, where you're
blowing your friends apart.
- [Gamer] God damn it.
(laughter)
- It's really fun to play
against each other in
death match.
And to influence everybody
in wanting to make games.
- [Narrator] And then the
guys at ID handed players
the keys to their kingdom
- [Man] We fully open the game.
Then we gave out the information
on the way that levels were created.
- [Narrator] DOOM was
opened up to modding.
Tech savvy players could now replace the
existing characters,
sound effects, textures
you name it with their own creations.
- [Man] People are starting
to make new graphics,
new weapons, new sounds for stuff.
It was basically everything that you see
in the game can be changed,
but we didn't allow anyone to modify DOOM
if they didn't buy it.
(laughing)
So if you have the
shareware version of DOOM
you can't run levels or mods or anything.
So that was actually kind of a way
of forcing people to buy it.
But also players want to be creative.
It's a lot easier to modify them than
to try and make a whole new thing.
So letting people mod a game
kind of gives them a taste
of what it's like to make a game,
and now the game, you
know, fits them better.
- [Narrator] DOOM was put in the hands
of players, and they made it their own.
- The game lives on forever.